already
that was one hell of a fly I need for me
I didn't even know I could do that
you should have seen it you should have
seen it it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you it was awesome newly
released body camera video is sparking
outrage in Florida after a recording
shows a Tampa officer bragging about
needing a suspect before swearing at and
taunting others nearby
you little bitch boy
that's right
hey come stand up to me I'm standing
right here
the incident happened on June 23 2022
but the video was released just this
week it shows Tampa police officer
dukajin maksuni arrive at a corner store
in the city
you ain't gonna get far fellas I
wouldn't worry about it almost
immediately after running from the squad
car max SUNY runs into the suspect
kneeing him so the man falls to the
ground
oh
yeah
after that maksuni can be heard swearing
for the first time
seconds after he made contact with the
suspect mcsooney begins bragging about
kneeing him that was one hell of a
flying knee for me guys
hey hey we got him relax
that was one hell of a fly to me for me
I didn't even know I could do that he
continues bragging saying the incident
was caught on body camera video
you should have seen it you should have
seen it it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you it was awesome video
then shows maksuni crossed the street
toward another group of people he begins
taunting the crowd saying he runs the
streets
hey you're not gonna do anything
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
what are you gonna do hey what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do come talk
to me now you want to say well your
tough guy come talk to me now
you little bitch boy
that's right
hey come stand up to me I'm standing
right here
[Music]
I need to know who runs the street today
and y'all
all the tough guys disappear now
[Music]
then for the third time maksuni brags
about me the suspect you should see the
flying either and he ran right into it
yeah
next body camera video captures Max SUNY
and others searching the scene
View
how far
there's a backpack back there too
hard to call from the jail
now
hey Aaron you're over here
a statement from the Tampa Police
Department reads in part quote the
officer's actions and statements were
unacceptable and failed to treat the
community with dignity and respect that
is the standard of the Tampa Police
Department
Tampa Police say the incident was
investigated back when it happened in
2022 officials say Max Sunni was
disciplined and quote removed from his
Squad in the neighborhood he served
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie